oui
printemps 2020 la pandémie une force la
population ou confinement person
l'épicerie devient source d'inquiétude
d'impatience les gens se tournent vers
les épiceries en ligne nous car on a
besoin indiqué faut être prêt savoir
frapper
c'était au départ un marginal et tout
d'un coup ça a été une explosion
les grandes bannières penta répondre à
la forte demande dans les premières
semaines de la pandémie mme on parle
d'augmentation de 500 pour sa de la
demande le site a planté au début ça
pouvait prendre quatre cinq jours avant
de pouvoir avoir une plage horaire
récupérer sa commande
on n'avait pas le personnel nécessaires
pour assembler les commandes qu'on a
engagé 500 personnes en quelques
semaines
très rapidement on est des journées des
semaines à 10 fois les dons a même fait
d'attendre virtuel pour gérer le nombre
des personnes qui rentrent sur le site
on a dû aussi s'ajuster pour les
marchandes augmenter la capacité
livraisons augmenter les plages horaires
même son cloche chez métro qui a presque
quadruplé ses ventes en ligne avant la
pandémie
c'était grosso modo 10 % de ce que les
québécois et québécoises acheter au
total passant en ligne mais dans le cas
de l'alimentation c'était très très très
très peu parlé essentiellement de -2 2%
arrive la pandémie et puis c'est monté
dans certains cas jusqu'à 35 pour ça en
quelques semaines les bannières sont
arrivés à des objectifs qu'elle pensait
atteindre en deux ou trois ans les epci
même les détaillants en alimentation
sont prêts parce que eux se préparent
depuis longtemps on sait bien que du
côté des iga en fait c'étaient les
précurseurs et ils sont depuis une
vingtaine d'années
métro a beaucoup investi l'eau blaze qui
arrive avec provigo white a été parmi
les plus là à bien des égards à
s'adapter au commerce électronique en
alimentation
maintenant tout le monde est à peu près
au même point et le coup de départ vient
d'être donné et tous les chevaux sont
prêtes
près de 1 ménages québécois sur dix dit
avoir essayé un service d'épicerie en
ligne pour la première fois pendant la
crise ce serait qu'une légère baisse
quand on est revenu une normalité mais
on parle quand même une augmentation de
280 % par rapport à l'an dernier
donc les gens qui ont découvert ce
service-là l'ont adopté et on pense que
ces locaux pour rester selon au sondage
42% des nouveaux et anciens adeptes
confondues affirme avoir l'intention de
maintenir cette habitude c'est le cas
d'emmanuel du moule et pourquoi pendant
la pandémie vous vous êtes tourné vers
l'épicerie en l'émoi l'ellipse piscine
de mes tâches favori de la semaine lost
est devenu un fardeau avec bon je suis
maman de deux petites filles de gêne
dans deux jeunes enfants habitués aux
plates formes en ligne de ces grands
joueurs en alimentation
emmanuel a accepté de faire son épicerie
en ligne devant notre caméra chez iga
maxi et métro
l'exercice était vraiment d'aller
sélectionnés pour trois bannières donc
dix produits frais 10 produits secs et
un petit peu congelée et puis on a
l'habitude avec le congeler quand vous
est fixé à la qualité du service a
commencé pour la disponibilité des
produits la rapidité de livraison
comment ça se passe normalement ça se
passe très bien
iga et laisser express dans notre camp
nou maxi nous appellent avec les listes
de substitution le service est vraiment
bien
oui donc au niveau du beurre oui on peut
mettre la marque sans nom sans problème
[ __ ] domicile c'est parfait parmi les
grandes bannières les seuls à ne pas
offrir le service d'appels téléphoniques
pour substitution sont wal mart et métro
et métro il substitution c'est une
surprise
je sais que vous aviez la volonté
d'avoir de la truite filet de truite
donc là on arrive on voit qu est ce qui
se passe eh bien oui je suis supposé
avoir de la truck mon filet de truite
pour super belle offre finalement
les paul a fait effectivement le filet
de truite qui ne disputent ce soir c'est
la première fois que le sait ça arrive
comme seul souvent je veux avoir quelque
chose pour pour compenser mais de par
mon expérience mes trousses ça me
surprend pas tant la question de la
substitution de produits non disponibles
est un des grands enjeux
mais si pci express comme en pays au
bourg samedi aucune substitution
disponibles
donc il n'ya pas répondre sur la facture
même chose pour le cocon j'essaie quand
même drôle parce que diogo puis des
concombres qui est pas de substitution
c'est quand même des examens malgré
quelques déceptions la qualité la
fraîcheur et la ponctualité et est au
rendez vous peu importe épicerie tester
mais ce que ça coûte plus cher de faire
l'épicerie en ligne
oui il ya toujours les frais
d'assemblage et de livraison donc quand
on n'a pas de bons ou de promotion c'est
sûr qu'il faut le cas depuis
présentement ya des frais d'assemblage
et de livraison qui sont minimes parce
qu'on pull quand même on fait sauver du
temps aux consommateurs alors des frais
qui varient du simple au double selon
les bannières mois comme consommatrice
dans un an est ce que mon et gm ont
coûté beaucoup plus cher pour payer
toutes les infrastructures vous avez dû
mettre de l'avant pour répondre à
l'extrême et les infrastructures ça fait
partie de notre capital développement
capital investissement capital on peut
payer le conservatoire pour ça dans la
course aux nouveaux clients en ligne
les bannières doivent maintenant
améliorer de services en région en
augmentant le territoire desservi par
livraison car en plus de ses épiceries
plusieurs autres entreprises voient tout
le potentiel de l'alimentation en ligne
et elles sont nombreuses
nos compétiteurs sont très agressifs
c'est un marché qui est très dynamique
oui à d'autres joueurs là qui en
attendant la livraison se débattre
paquinou des produits d'épicerie et une
hôtesse top model en ontario où on livre
des produits de restauration où on livre
aussi des boîtes repas en plus de
commandes des gens donc on teste ce
qu'il ya de la place pour tout ce monde
là oui de la place pour tout le monde là
si on adapte bien sa logistique de
distribution
si on a fait que ajouté une fonction de
commerce électronique sans repenser ses
magasins ça va être beaucoup trop
coûteux parce que ce que l'on va faire
comme consommateur sur le web on ne le
fera plus en magasin
et c'est là qu'elle grandit fille dans
cette révolution commerciale en cours
les épiceries revoient leur stratégie
qui passe de plus en plus par des
entrepôts automatisés ont fait des tests
en ontario on a par exemple ce qu'on
appelle un mini centre
d'approvisionnement qui est semi
automatisé c'est un convoyage va
apporter les produits qu'ils
apparaissent sur une commande une
commande peut prendre peut-être une
heure à faire une grosse commande en
ligne
lorsqu on le fait chez iga on est en
train de construire notre beau
présentement dans ce contexte si ça va
prendre environ 5000 ça permet d'avoir
plus de volume en peu de temps on fait
des grands investissements là dessus
parce qu'on sait que présentement un
niveau croissant sas exceptionnelle en
ligne mais l'expérience en magasin va
toujours rester je pense que ce qui
serait bien ce serait que les deux
modèles puissent coexister ensemble
c'est ce qu'on préconise c'est ce qu'on
pense qui va perdurer 20 ans est ce que
vous seriez capable maintenant de vous
passer de ce service avez vous
l'impression que vous avez l'utilisé
encore d'abord
joue sur ma sûrement à l'occasion mais
vu que moi j'aime bien y aller battre
temps en temps c'est agréable d'aller
mettre les pipes choisir nos produits
[Musique]